[Music]  one of these pampered Cubs is about to  be chosen for the mission of a lifetime  her objective helped expand the wild  panda population  [Music]  Kempton was born in captivity so  learning to thrive in the wild won't be  easy  she'll need help from some unexpected  places  to discover her own inner bear I don't  teach bears how to be bears the  knowledge is already inside  join the team of Chinese and American  scientists working together to help chen  chen prepare for the wild  [Music]  come on it's cool  [Music]  Warner Brothers pictures and IMAX invite  you to share a journey of friendship  a struggle for survival  and the story of  so much  [Music]  some of you  [Music]  panda narrated by Kristen Bell hey  that's me experience it in IMAX  [Music]  [Music]